[Music]
hello everyone
uh so again my name is eduardo arino de
la rubia you can't follow me on social
media anymore because all my accounts
are locked down
too bad i'm awesome uh but if you want
you can follow me on linkedin
so first a disclaimer uh this is not a
talk about facts
if you wanted to go to a talk about
facts there's an awesome gg plot talk
going on right now there's just great
talks going on this is the wrong talk if
you wanted facts
this is a talk about opinions okay and
they're my opinions they're not my
current esteemed
employer they're not previous awesome
employers they're not my wife they're
not my sweet angel mother this is
just me if you got a problem with me
with my opinions
let's have it out let's have a great
discussion um and very if you're a
scientist working
we had somebody earlier at a cancer
research lab and things like that
this ain't about your space either i
don't know anything about your space
this is about data science
in business uh i think it's also
important to give you a little bit of
context uh i'm
sad uh to report that i'm no longer an
ic i'm no longer an individual
contributor
uh i'm not even a manager anymore it's
absolutely repugnant i'm a manager of
managers
uh you're getting a real sort of
different point of view
here than you do from a lot of the
practitioners at this conference you've
had
world-class practitioner after
practitioner after practitioner tell you
about
the craft that they've honed this is a
totally different perspective
i used to be one of those folks and now
instead mostly i sit around in meetings
and think about the design of
organizations
in the last couple of years i have built
spun up and handed off
at least two dozen data science
organizations across multiple time zones
so take it for what you will
uh and more importantly any sufficiently
advanced trolling
is indistinguishable from thought
leadership uh
this is just a fact and i'm a cage
fighting referee so like let's do this
like am i trolling you is this real
let's make it happen all right
so of course there's a data science
conference so i want to talk about
webmasters
uh webmasters uh existed for a very long
time and tell me if this sounds familiar
they were individuals who had an
incredibly rare set of skills all inside
one meet human and they were able to do
amazing things
and they were incredibly well paid and
no one really understood
what they did this is an article from
1997 already saying that these folks are
making 60 to 90 grand
i don't know about you but it's a lot
later than 1997 and 90 grand is still a
pretty sweet salary
and so these webmasters existed and so
why did they exist what did they do
every time in technology there is some
fundamental evolution
you find these roles pop up for some
period of time
what webmasters did if you're old like i
am you remember working at a business
and being like
hey stephanie we need 27 flanges and
stephanie would take out a book
and go to f for flanges and call or file
a purchase order
and that's how business happened as
human beings had were forced to talk to
each other
and exchange documents and [ __ ] like
that and
uh what happened was that that was
incredibly inefficient and capitalism
demands
a push towards efficiency and so
webmasters brought offline businesses
to online uh here is what's happened to
webmasters by the way like this is
google trends
and it only goes back to 2008 imagine
what it would look like if we were to
look now but even
2008 2009 11 12 there was still some
sort of trend and there was a massive
collapse
there is no such thing as a webmaster in
any real sense
maybe you've got a little website you
want to call yourself the webmaster
that's awesome
but the massive set of skills that were
required to transform an entity from
offline into online no longer really
exist inside of a single human
so where'd they go it used to be a
webmaster i remember being
a webmaster at a company and it was me
and there was
a thousand rando i.t dudes that did lord
knows what to keep the cobalt
systems going and all of those people
basically have had to be re-skilled
and now they're a front-end engineer a
back-end engineer a cloud architect a
site reliability engineer a network
engineer a test engineer
the entire world that was the webmaster
role
exploded to become what is basically
technology careers of today
not all of them but a significant number
of them job titles are
fragile responsibilities that prove
themselves in adding value to the
business become
durable so is the death of webmasters is
actually a story about success
uh businesses went online
instead of changing online instead of
changing the internet which
happened a little bit what really
happened was businesses
changed it wasn't a business going
online it was a business transforming to
become an
online business the way that business
was done fundamentally changed
software ate the world as that famous
quote says and by software i mean like
this online
interconnected friction reducing thing
that now happens that allows me to take
my pocket glass
box of horrors and push a button and get
a pizza or a car delivered to me
right business fundamentally changed and
you couldn't know
you couldn't scale that if you were
looking for one person or two people who
had this massive set of skills
okay so now you're like cool we're at
your studio conference what does this
have to do with values and data science
beyond models in production
hold on i'm coming to it uh because this
is a really interesting chart right so
if you take google trends and you
overlay webmaster and you overlay data
science as a field of study
they have this really neat intersection
that happens shortly after the release
of google panda
do people know what google panda is
google panda was this
massive seismic shift in which google
said
quality matters and we're creating
quality
guidelines and suddenly seo and sem
advice
all overnight disappeared there were all
of these incredible tricks and tips and
people who were making their entire
career on
you got to do this thing with the meta
keywords and you got to buy these links
in this link exchange and you got to do
keyword stuffing and comment spamming
and blah blah blah blah
and all of that went away google's
entire quality algorithm moved to
machine learning they ended up training
massive data sets based on human
rated statements of this website as
quality this and this website doesn't
have
quality seo advice became try
to make good content
this is a massive shift suddenly the
entire world of people selling content
online and selling attention online
basically became actually like we can't
make crap tutorials and hope
you know that like we capture enough
time to get somebody to like click on
some random
car ad or or lord knows what ad it
actually they had to figure out how to
make good content and it turned out
that's difficult
so what's the parallel right the
parallel is that a webmaster took an
offline business and turned it into an
online business
a data scientist takes a process and
rules-based
business and turns it into an
algorithmic business
what this really fundamentally means is
they could no longer work on the process
of we're going to stuff these meta
keywords we're going to buy these link
exchanges
they have to constantly be experimenting
to understand
what is quality would actually rake sire
what are the characteristics of the data
that we present in the narrative that we
present that actually end up being
incentivized by the google algorithm
and this happened not just across
content businesses but across basically
the entire spectrum of business
data scientists often turn process
businesses into algorithmic businesses
so here's one of my first hot takes uh
data science hype
is not real it's actually machine
learning hype
okay and uh this is where it gets
interesting right uh why because machine
learning
is the thing that engineers know how to
embed into existing software systems
data scientists do not have sustainable
advantage over
engineers in producing models of
sufficient quality which can be
leveraged in production
right now in the world there are massive
advances happening
in how you make machine learning models
when you don't know statistics
companies are building end-to-end
tooling that fundamentally makes it
possible for an engineer
to build a good enough model
and data scientists organizations which
are ml focused if your data science
organization principally is an
organization that makes ml models
you are either going to become an
engineering organization or if we talked
right now
and i pushed you would admit that you
are an engineering organization
principally
or you will replace right engineering
organizations if your data science team
focuses on adding value other than
models in production
i feel and predict that your
organization is going to flourish
by the way somebody asked me what do i
mean by production production is the set
of hardware and software systems where
money is made
that is what i mean by production there
is no other magical concept of
production
and so just as like if you overlay the
google trends of the field of study of
data science in the field of study of
machine learning i understand that the
world is full of spurious correlations
but i argue that like this is not one of
them right like the data science hype
cycle
is intrinsically tied to the machine
learning hype cycle
and let's be clear today there's 15 408
data science jobs on monster.com
but there's 17 931 machine learning jobs
right so it's one of those things that
like i want to make keep making this
point that actually like
machine learning is not going to be the
data scientists competitive advantage
it is going to be other aspects of what
they do
and lastly if you don't believe me that
you
don't have a competitive advantage
automl tools are getting
pretty darned good here's a tweet from
aaron liddell if you don't know her i
believe she's the
chiefs research scientist at what
chief machine learning scientist thank
you very much audience member
for h2o uh she's absolutely brilliant
and she works a lot on automl she i
believe her
her phd was on actually ensembling and
banging of models i don't remember the
specifics
quite frankly automl is getting pretty
darn good
and i hear you saying oh but that was a
kaggle data set
that wasn't uh the real world data
doesn't look like that
so i've already made the argument that
ml engineers are likely going to take
the ml work that data scientists do to
add value
here's my hot take there's already a
group of people that do this better than
data scientists
it's called a data engineer a data
engineer is a
whole field they've got a journal like
they exist
right they develop and construct
architecture data acquisition
they prepare data for predictive and
prescriptive modeling
the idea that data scientists have some
sort of
moat around massaging data and making it
useful
is wrong at scale in production
data engineers have an incredible series
of advantages on them
and let's be clear i believe that in
mature organization
data engineers are the product owners of
the data product
here's one of my hot takes think about
the analyses that you do
if to do your analysis you're having to
join
more than a couple of tables you don't
have well-designed data products and you
need a data engineer
so what have we got left we've taken
away ml modeling we've taken away the
massaging of data we've taken all these
things
let's quit mid talk summary i'm not
claiming that these responsibilities are
going away as a matter of fact if you
remember i said that this is because of
the success that these responsibilities
are so durable i'm actually claiming
that
much like offline became online and
businesses became online
data informed is the dna of the of the
business
i'm definitely not claiming that data
scientist is a bad job
i don't know that the title is going to
exist for a real long time
but the job is freaking awesome pays
real well and allows you to do some
amazing stuff
uh i'm not claiming i am claiming that
whether it's this year
or a few years down the road your value
will not be ml in production
and this is a side effect of success
okay
so now we talk about what do i think
data science organizations can do other
than ml in production right
where do data scientists have a
competitive advantage
so you've probably heard the phrase that
the product managers are the ceo
of a product right that's the
fundamental theory of the product
manager
we have actually a pm job
responsibilities on the left
ceo job responsibilities on the right
it's really about the scale that you're
looking at right are you looking at an
individual product or set of features
are you looking at the entire company
but realistically i believe this i
believe that if you're working in a
standard product team the product
manager is the ceo
okay well guess what i believe that data
scientists are the cfo
of product teams so the cfo is
responsible in a traditional company for
determining and reporting the financial
information
if money is a resource the cfo is
responsible for making sure that that
resource is accounted for appropriately
is going to the right things that there
isn't any weird fraud or leakage
they are the ones who make sort of like
these they make decisions about how
this resource is allocated
the cfo is to money like data scientists
are to attention
and effort you are the ones who have the
incredible power of deciding
what you f what the team focuses on what
the team builds
what the company is looking to build
this is the key
i believe of why data scientists
responsibilities are incredibly durable
does your company really understand what
drives its success and capabilities
right now are you prepared to say that
you really truly understand
exactly why your company is where it is
where it's going where it's successful
where it's not
have you done the six foundational
analyses have you done them
recently can you talk to your company
about this allocation of resources and
this true understanding
have you understood when people use your
product why they use it and why they
stay
have you understood when people fail to
use your products somehow
how is it they're failing what happened
how did they get there and were they
able to self-remediate
have you understood your power users the
fact of the matter is that a power law
distribution almost certainly
is happening inside of your inside of
your product do you understand these
power users the ones that are driving
your features they're driving what
you're doing
do you understand in your
experimentation framework why it is that
you need to be very careful about power
users because they will dominate the
statistics of your a b
tests if you're not careful and you end
up just making your product better and
better and better for the one percent of
people
who were already never going to leave
your product in the first place
are you doing enough segmentation
analysis do you understand where your
product is strong where your product is
weak which country loves it which
country hates it which group of people
love it which group of people hate it
do you know this is it operationalized
have you done an ecosystem analysis do
you understand
if for every one minute that is used in
hypothetically our studio
is that negative 30 seconds in jupiter
notebooks
is it incremental too is it instead of
what is happening inside of the broader
ecosystem that you function
have you done an inflection point
analysis do you understand what it takes
to drive
long-term growth and adoption not just
one step wins
do you have a large enough hold back
that you can understand how a person
who hasn't received any your treatments
over a year is different how a person
who's received every marketing message
over the previous year
do you have this deep understanding
about where the resources the attention
and the skills of your organization are
being spent
to get real specific now like what are
the ways that data orgs
add value number one is metric design
are you monitoring what you should do
you have the right metrics in place does
your metric actually
measure not just the immediate value of
an a b test but the longitudinal value
do you have the right counter metrics in
place
is it possible that you're increasing
the click-through rate but destroying
the adoption
or destroying the renewal do you have
the basket of metrics you've proven time
and time again
that have the characteristics to help
you be by being real proxies to the
things that are stated in your company
values
it maybe maybe not do you measure right
are you sure you're logging
everything well do you work with your
engineers to make sure that like at
every single screen
everything is logged so that all of your
experiments aren't actually telling you
something about the data generating
process of improper logging
as opposed to as opposed to actually
with the user's experience really really
i'm loving the nods by the way those are
you nodding like
you're giving me life right uh like no
this is this is a big deal like
if you're not measuring properly if
you're not measuring consistently
you're always chasing noise your
organization is not chasing a
signal goaling i actually believe is the
single thing that data science
organizations need to own
with ferocity there is no more powerful
thing in
organizing a group of people to take a
mountain take an objective or do an
audacious thing
than a goal that is at this perfect
sweet spot of audacious
but believable do you as an organization
have a formal practice for determining
what is a 50 50 goal
a goal that you will not hit half the
time a 90 10 goal
a 1090 goal do you understand which one
of the metrics you should actually go
along do you understand whether you
should be going on the operational
metrics or the tracking metrics
do you have all of this in place is it a
road machine that adds value to the
business
every quarter every half i wanted to
actually point out i said
no values in production that's not the
models but you're still going to be
doing modeling
modeling is still going to be an
important part of your life right
sometimes you still need to make a model
that can be the best way to size an
opportunity to understand what's going
on thank you i see the time
you're going to end up doing it and r is
a fantastic tool
to make these incredibly fast models to
make them quickly and to be able to
educate the business
more stuff are you creating enough
self-service tools every time that you
are getting
feedback from a business partner that uh
that you need something done are you
asking yourself
is now the appropriate time to turn this
into something that we leverage
just a quick shout out here to our
studio connect i think that is a
fantastic tool for our organizations
that are trying to do
this exact thing but if you're not
building self-service tools as part of
your practice
you're leaving value to the organization
on the table prioritization
any one engineering company any one
company building a
thing can build a hundred different
features onto the thing
how are you choosing which one should be
built on average ratio and i'm not
saying it's a good or bad ratio for
every one
data scientist analytics person whatever
you want to call them there's a minimum
of
10 engineers let's make that clear
standard silicon valley salary that's
two million dollars worth of salary
right 10 times 200 000
that one data scientist driving the
prioritization of those 10 silicon
valley engineers
is making the choice whether two million
dollars worth of human capital is
building a feature
that is going to be good or a feature
that is actually not going to be used or
a feature that people don't really want
right off of all of the analysis we did
earlier which is a thing that you do via
opportunity sizing
like i said there's 10 things that can
be done but which one
should be right are you working on a
feature that only your power users are
going to use are you using on a feature
that is going to be a fundamental lever
to the
sustained adoption of your product if
you're not doing that opportunity sizing
you're not being a good cfo of your
company
and obviously experimentation right uh
it's incredible hum
i'm not gonna do a show of hands things
but if you've ever worked with an
engineer who set up an a b
test and said oh yeah but we made it
real easy for people to opt in and opt
out of the a b
test like have you had that experience
have you had to explain to them how they
no longer have an a b test how there's
no longer an experiment there
and all that you're measuring is now
bias you as the data science
organization
add that value by being the people who
make sure that experiments are actually
meaningful
and how the data orgs add value hey
there's this little thing called ethics
oftentimes data scientists in an
organization are the ones who have the
most
training on ethical decision making it's
just a fact if you look at an
engineering curriculum at least when i
did my undergrad computer science uh
curriculum there was one one hour class
on ethics in which we learned about
utilitarianism in deontology
it was not exactly a useful course data
scientists have often times in graduate
school work with real human subjects
if you haven't you you if you have great
if you haven't you need to learn about
this because almost certainly
somewhere in your value chain there's
humans check out the menlo report for
really great principles on
on ethics respect for persons
beneficiaries justice
and a respect for law and public
interest this is something that as a
data organization you can add a lot of
value to your company by making sure
that
your experiments your prioritization
your goal in is always being done from
an ethical perspective
wrapping up the future of the data
science is
the future of business there is no
difference you
as data scientists add value by making
every part of that business data
informed that is our competitive
advantage and
that is the value other than another
freaking model in production
that you are adding to the business
my two little pitches if you haven't
read these two books
read these two books if you don't know
how to if you've never taken formal
negotiation coursework
learn it these are the two most
important books that i can suggest to
you right now
because in all of these things that i've
discussed how the data science teams add
value it's through communication
negotiation and influence and these will
be superpowers
and last but not least hey fist bumps
all right there's a global epidemic
right here so uh no
no high fives no handshaking fist bumps
uh against uh wuhan coronavirus
so thank you for your time i am hiring
i'm looking for data scientists in the
bay area seattle and zurich
feel free to email me at iorino
gmail.com thank you
thank you eduardo we have uh time for
one question and it's it's it's the most
popular one on this list and it's coming
from
concerned data scientists what are the
fundamental differences between a
regular organization and an
engineering organization
so what does an engineering organization
do engineering is the practice of
how right engineering cares about how
things are done not why they are done
right and so what is an engineering
organization an engineering organization
cares deeply about how and cares deeply
about the creation of
our artifacts that they themselves have
some life afterwards either be a
a piece of code it'd be usually a piece
of code
or a piece of hardware that's one of the
fundamental differences
is that at the end of the day you're
going you want to be a data scientist my
guess is you want to ask questions about
causality you want to ask
why questions you want to understand
deeper if you're in an engineering
organization it's
fine but expect to spend your life
answering how questions
thank you very much thank you everyone
for attending this segment
[Music]